see this is where owning the Ghostbuster
vehicles or fun you know the other
vehicles that have been in movies
whatever bad writers or something out of
the calcaneus collection you never know
actually you know what it's interesting
I do have to Teslas that are
collectibles that I do want to figure
out what to do with yep because I'm
having a garage space issue and I offer
I was gonna come back to Elon but he's
got too many cars as well so I have
Tesla serial number one signature of the
model roadster of the Model S idea okay
io number 16 of the roadster okay so
they did the signature 100 of roadster I
have number 16 and then I have the
signature number one of the first
thousand signatures of the Model S well
I paid a hundred fifty for each of those
so three hundred thousand dollars in
essence what do you think they're worth
so because they would be worth less as
you use Tesla's but yes because the
market hasn't started these are only
five ten year old cars correct I mean
the the roadsters I think are trading in
the 50 60 grand range yeah the signature
ones are more and and the fact you know
we've got some celebrity ownership here
so that obviously adds something to it
and then the fact that it's early like
that and and one owner they would that
make it go up I think it would and I
think I'd love to do that deal with you
really yes I would consider it only
because I I don't want to drive them
anymore I realize they have a value yeah
I I would yeah I would do it sure put
the two of them up yeah as one
collection we could do it that way or
individually whatever whatever I put
them both up for what I paid for it
three hundred thousand no I'd be a
little more four hundred thousand mm-hmm
if I put the two of them up for four
hundred K then I would be even plus a
hundred and I keep 25% of the shares for
myself so I basically break even but I
have twenty five percent ownership in
them on the upside that's exactly the
kind of deals we put together oh is it
really yeah see I think that's the
interesting thing for me because I don't
need the money
but I also don't want to have these in
my house I'd rather have you maintaining
them they can use a little cleanup here
and there like a couple scratches
whatever you do that polish them up kind
of thing or usually yeah usually before
we take them in we have everything up to
up to the point where their collector
grade in that say I upgraded the battery
on the Roadster to the 300 mile one
that's amazing but okay so we probably
have to do 10k worth of work on them to
clean them on and we could pull that
right into the deal
yeah maybe I think I want to do it only
because I want to buy more cars there
you go this is this is this is the
problem we help solve I mean it's the
problem for rich 1% [ __ ] who like
cars in part I want to because the thing
is here's what I want I want those two
cars to be protected and preserved
forever for other people to see and
share agreed so I was gonna give it to
the Smithsonian as a donation if I could
get like whatever some sick donation for
them that you know if they're
collectibles let's say I got the
donation for them for 500,000 and had to
pay taxes that year because a cab
company I was selling chairs in maybe I
had a profit then maybe I could get some
portion of my money back and they would
be in the Smithsonian forever but I
don't trust those guys the Smithsonian
with an electric car maybe all right
let's make a deal okay because I'm a
celeb we give Jerry it wasn't Jerry
Seinfeld card you bought it for we
bought it from somebody who bought it
from Jerry Seinfeld so yeah we didn't we
didn't go direct so wait what am I
negotiating you know we're gonna do our
research we have to check these out I
wonder if I want verification records we
have to make sure this is done right how
about an email from that'll help perfect
I need to have you on sign the dashboard
I guess I gotta get a permanent marker
without increased value I think it would
in this case in this case yes yes yeah I
think this would it be great all right
and we what would I be negotiating the
deal we're kind of aligned it's not like
you have some fees or so oh you get 3%
yeah but I don't know that's that's well
grant Yeah right it's more about getting
the right getting it out there getting
the right people how about this hmm if
we put the first one or if we put the
collection in the rally Road showroom
yes with my book in it and a photo of me
and I can move some books in New York
and then all the people in New York well
no who said I would never become
anything when we forced to go to rally
Road see my Tesla there for sale oh you
know we both come from Brooklyn so yes
we're about Carroll Gardens Brooklyn
okay I got yeah and I went to school and
barrage like you did severe Ian
no but Alfie I went to Poly Prep but I
went to Poly Prep I did but one our
first our first employee on the team
is this variance oh very good